the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so you mentioned before like we're
talking about Trump not only in the
popular vote so how do you feel about
our system of voting in the United
States versus like a preferential voting
system well that's a kind of her it's a
fact known among political scientists
but not the population that the American
political system is so regressive that
it would not be accepted by the European
Court of Justice literally the some of
the East European states that have come
into the European Union have proposed
voting systems like the American one
they're rejected because they're so
undemocratic this goes back to the if
you take a look at them we don't have
any political parties in the United
States remember they do in Europe a
political you can't be a member of the
Democratic Party what you can do is go
into the voting booth and put an X
somewhere that's your role as a citizen
elite party managers set up the programs
and pretty much picked the can't you
know they vet two candidates only
certain ones get through when you get
you look at a ballot it says Republican
Democrat nothing else those are your
choices so these are candidate producing
machines the role of the citizen is to
show up every couple of years and put in
an X and then go home that's not
democratic politics
[Music]
but that's a deeply ingrained system it
comes out of the way the party system
developed here in the 19th century
post-civil war mainly so that's I mean
these are really serious issues it makes
it almost impossible for an independent
party to participate and those things
are not graven and stone you know they
can all be changed earlier concerns
about blacks in America well you go back
to the slavery lasted until the Civil
War and incidentally it was the most
vicious system of slavery in world
history there was never anything like it
slavery is bad enough but the American
system was unique also the it's worth
remembering that the slave system is the
basis of our prosperity the main
commodity in the early 19th century was
cotton cotton was the fuel of the 19th
century Industrial Revolution cheap
cotton led to the manufacturing
industries in New England the early
manufacturing at big manufacturing
industries in Lowell and Lawrence for
textiles led to the development of the
financial system credit loans and so on
was mostly for the cotton based system
Sam in England
that's why Liverpool was one of the
richest countries and then you know in
the world where the slave cotton came in
so cotton if you look at it was the base
real basis right through the 19th
century for commercial and industrial
development and was based on extremely
cheap and highly productive labor the
productivity of labour was
improved by technology but the
technology was very simple it was the
whip and the pistol that's all you
needed to improve technology the whole
story is unbelievably hideous when you
look at it
okay theoretically it ended it was the
Emancipation Declaration but that was
only theoretical
there was a 10-year period of
reconstruction in which federal troops
were in the South Union troops and
that's one of the decades in which
African Americans had a small chance to
get into the system and they did they
were elected they were there were people
running towns and legislatures there was
a bit of Economic Development and so on
it ended in 1877 with the north-south
compact that essentially let the South
free to do whatever it wanted so what
they did was reinstituted slavery
literally in fact the main book on this
is called slavery by another name wall
street journal' the bureau chief who
studied it in some depth I mean
scholarship that known at the wrote a
good popular book about it and what
happened was black life was criminalized
so if a black man is standing on a
street corner he can be charged with
vagrancy and given a fine which you
can't pay so he's in jail forever and
the black man look something says
somebody looked at a white woman okay
he's in charge he's charged with
attempted rape was in jail for the rest
of his life pretty soon most of the
black male population was in jail that's
a wonderful slave labor force from the
point of view of the capitalist it's
much better than slavery because you
don't have to sustain your workforce if
you have slaves you have to keep them
alive
if it's a prison population the taxpayer
keeps them alive you just get the profit
and a large part of the second
wave of industrialization in the United
States was based on that mining steel so
on used essentially incarcerated slave
labor
I mean we're familiar with the chain
gangs because you see them you know the
AG work we don't see them but you didn't
see them the agricultural workers but it
was happening all over the economy well
that lasted almost until the Second
World War and now we have another
version of it you know the high end
partially massive incarceration since
the Reagan years kind of reconstituted
that in many ways well all of this has
to do with voting these people our vote
what's more we have very harsh voting
laws people convicted of what's called a
felony which could be you know being
caught with pot three times or something
they don't vote anymore they're out of
the system and this is a big part of it
both of their families are destroyed so
they know you know they live in I mean I
once took a walk through and it with a
sociologist friend through studies these
things and through an area of the Bronx
which I happen to know from childhood
just a lot of my family lived there
these to be immigrant communities poor
communities they were but now they've
been gentrified you know high-rises and
so on a night I asked asked this woman
sociologist from Columbia what happened
to the people and she said well the men
are in jail and upstate New York and the
women and children sort of followed them
so they can visit them on Sunday you
know so they're in upstate New York and
now the rich people live here things
like captain that is happening in South
Boston
we've seen it you know in my lifetime
that's happening all over the country
these are things that are going on
constantly right in front of our eyes
and voting sure it's knocking a large
part of the population out of the voting
list along with by now as I'm sure you
know the Republicans particularly are
dedicated to trying to reduce the vote
because the more people vote the more
trouble they're in so you have all these
ludicrous Jeff Sessions the Department
of Justice head at the part of Justice
is now in charge of trying to figure out
ways to what they call prevent voter
fraud there's virtually no voter fraud I
mean so miniscule it's difficult
undetectable but that claim to try to
readjust voting so that you can keep
poor and black people out like the
United States is the French election if
you noticed was on Sunday there's a good
reason for that Sunday people are free
so they can go in the vote here it's on
a work day making it hard to vote except
for the rich they can do it easily if
you're an executive you know leave your
office your college professor mean take
off you know but for a lot of people you
just can't vote on a work day and there
are all sorts of other rules now you
have to have a driver's license photo
IDs a lot of people don't have that okay
people and all kind of along with the
gerrymandering which is by no joke the
many devices are being used to try to
prevent the limited democratic system
from functioning but again all of this
can be changed
bigger gains have been won in the past
I mean look at what just take that I
forget blacks think about women I mean
if you go back to the early days of the
Republic the women were not considered
people literally they were property in
our constitutional system in the early
days a woman is the property of her
father which is transferred over to her
husband then she's his property in fact
if you take a look at the early debates
about whether women should be allowed to
vote one of the arguments against it was
that it would be unfair to unmarried men
because a married man would have two
votes his own both in the properties
vote and this lasted for a long time
until pretty recently
it wasn't until 1975 it's not that far
back that women had a right to serve on
federal juries meaning being treated as
peers that's a half the population it's
not african-americans
it's been a long way to go to achieve
some kind of real right and a lot has
been achieved a lot of victories sign of
where you can go there's a lot of things
we take for granted we just didn't exist
years back I would say take this class
when I came to MIT in 1955 it was white
males period well dress ties and jackets
deferential figure homework that was MIT
that's not what it is no that didn't
happen that way but changed by magic